[Music]
[Applause]
this week we've got village of boners
who
super nanny take down and vine
resurrection take away Tiffany
[Music]
is that post or now I started [ __ ]
itchy home I never white turn around and
show everybody you could have been it's
all alive complete no no no you never
moved your body from itching so hard
like you never did one of those oh I did
but I usually do it off camera ah
professional that's no cameras well only
friends I forgot that was a camera yeah
it's a front first story there's this
Irish village called ringa skiddy hmm it
already sounds like a village full of
boners yeah and so the pharmaceutical
firm Pfizer which is the Pfizer / Pfizer
by the way [ __ ] those guys they don't
pay taxes but they are a sponsor of this
podcast I watched a documentary on a
Netflix and then they're showing how
like Google Pfizer all these other big
ass companies they paid zero taxes Dan
so [ __ ] them cuz we need better roads
and [ __ ] I'm still down with that brand
deal though from Pfizer sponsor us what
does the Pfizer do there they do like
buy a bra in all of that yeah well I
knew that the Pfizer this village here
this Irish village is where they produce
viagra and so the villagers here are
saying that the fumes just have guys and
dogs walking around with boners all the
time all right guys and dogs and I mean
it guys have boners bar in my mind I
visualized the dog but guys came out so
I meant to say dog yeah dog dog neurons
are only two seasons are affected by
this well hard Roberto species species
Birds armadillos cats how about all the
other they have a bone in their dick
maybe it's out of the fur coat okay I
like that question answered though do
birds have dicks
I've never seen a bird day I've ever
seen Birds [ __ ] yeah yeah they get on
top of each other and [ __ ] really
like a missionary or right yup that's
right ox our APIs gang gray first I for
today
like a PBS special also ducks rain she
said it like she was telling of a
classroom full of fire
don't be ducks guys that doesn't want it
we call that duck Weinstein yeah so
they're just saying like yeah you know
people the guys that live here they
never have to worry about erectile
dysfunctions all you got to do is just
whiff and get this how do they pay
attention women to like wouldn't they be
walking around with like giant clitoris
yeah like a stiff clitoris yeah because
it's clitoris is to the right it's
better I Taurus what happens to women
when they take viagra Big Brother do you
think any it was invented as a
circulation drug right and then they
found out it makes it vasodilate in the
penis so all your blood rushes to that
area so it would generally be the same
for a female I think but just like we
would have like baby dicks like a gorge
clitoris yeah super engorged oh that's
hot maybe yeah baby dick poking out of
your under I know that's been kind of
like your nipple you get a [ __ ] [ __ ]
ring what is that it's like a pinky so
every time they jog the dick gets hard
but I have jerked off a dog my own dog
never said this out question did you use
the fur coat or did you touch the dead
lipstick just backtrack a little bit
just start from the very beginning how
did it happen what made you curious how
did you know okay because whatever
though yes they don't require you to
spay or neuter your dogs right a very
young age I was able to see that he was
obviously very horny and not getting
what he needed so as a good dog owner
how old were you you know what my friend
did this all me no look
like we're crazy as a good dog
I'll go are you [ __ ] like we're doing
actually look at her like she is normal
and we're [ __ ] up you're [ __ ] don't
let you definitely don't go home and
jerk off your dog but I want to hear
your story because I feel like if you
don't neuter your dog and you let them
live a life without sex that's
essentially like telling a human or
forcing them into a convent mm-hmm yeah
like you're saying here have all this
you know juice and the giant raging
boner but never do anything with it
that's unfair so I couldn't let my dog
live like that and I was eight years old
I was like you know what I'm gonna do a
good D and drink my obstacle yeah how
did you know that like how did you know
to do this very you must have been the
best at family parties every time you
help the basketball you're like oh there
goes final again ruffles and roll the
ADA oh my god rub there's a German
Shepherd don't take this the wrong way
guys I know I think that's awesome I
don't go to your home and like no you're
staying away from everybody's dog I know
such a cute dog
best Greg get the [ __ ] up yeah where are
your hands I really got a dog world
there'd be a picture of me I'd be like I
like an sainthood basically like thank
you very much is the fur collar yes I
think probably just the base yeah oh so
not even that I was like was it she was
um
Rolly was a mix one was a German
Shepherd and it was a Shiba Inu oh poor
God yeah I don't know as a parent if I
walked out on my daughter doing that now
I wouldn't scream if I just saw I don't
give a [ __ ] your worries in a scream oh
if you're eight it's kind of like the
doggies humping a basketball you go
all's the doggy stressed out let me help
the dog you're like instinctually I just
sock my kid what
oh [ __ ] my mom never taught me how to
deal with uncomfortable situations so
what that's not even an uncomfortable
situation is it because my mom didn't
teach me anything about sex mother so it
is uncomfortable so if I were to see
that if you're my daughter and I see
that I would pretend like oh [ __ ] I
didn't see that night we just walk away
I would screams oh you turned out a gene
yeah and I'd be like my [ __ ]
daughters but we did kid well you're not
alone in this because in high school I
had a friend that would do that too yeah
yeah he would say that I want to give my
dog release and I'm like oh [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] crazy I would never touch my dog
that way but I wouldn't do that for a
friend he was showing us a doggy in the
back and started [ __ ] jerking him off
like yeah who's the asian crazy Filipino
is it like some kind of thing I could
just picture you doing it while you
crack coconuts with your feet like this
or or or they're just nurturing right
yeah see if I just put myself in a doggy
shoes if I was a dog and I was [ __ ] a
basketball all day I wouldn't want
someone to help me out
you want to Filipino to help you out for
you yeah is Peter gonna come after me I
don't know I think they'll give you a
war actually like we're all [ __ ] up
but we should learn from that I feel
like no because my dogs are spayed and
neutered or spayed and neutered but if
they're not that's [ __ ] up like they
got blue balls yeah he doesn't even have
balls who your dog as I'm saying but if
they had balls and then they weren't
spade and neuter I think we should be
jacking them off I don't think so
you heard here Bart said we should I
think you just inspired him to start a
whole new revenue foundation yeah it's
gonna come up the pie so just slap it in
the morning come on man come on it's the
doctor just a dog jerk Center Tyson's
dead David what the [ __ ]
oh wait I keep plugging enticing ah
now can I just call meatloaf Tyson do
she just just like my mom the double
name plane save yeah alright so for our
next story that was this babysitter
Hussein care of the kids that she had
singer of in the home when she realized
that there was a package thief outside
with at home this is she tackled that
[ __ ] [ __ ] show you guys in the
video yes I love these videos [ __ ]
hit those Amazon thieves the [ __ ]
laughter the funny thing is the driver
freaked out because all you had to do or
so you had to wait like three seconds
for but the funny thing is it took her
so long to get to the day so it's like
let me wait three seconds and then
[ __ ] hit the pedals yeah why isn't it
getaway car so far away the way that
girl ran it was like shed an invisible
[ __ ] rubber banner on her ankles her
strides are so small dude that [ __ ]
friend conversation is gonna be awkward
as hell needed three more seconds she
was almost in the closing three seconds
her foot was it that's true she was
inside yeah what if that was her
boyfriend that's a breakup weren't there
dating mmm it almost looked like he
pushed her off yeah sacrifice tell her
you were checking the address do you
guys get any packages checked we did
once right
oh yeah I ordered shoes and
I came outside and I there wasn't there
and even though the tracking number said
it was supposed to be there and I
started walking down and in my next-door
neighbors bushes was always torn up
packages oh that's how I think they took
it they took out the stuff that was
inside and they tore up the package and
I stuffed it in the bushes I know you
got your camera stolen at the office
somebody in the office complex sign for
my package for my for my camera and they
took it you know what they signed for a
package this is this [ __ ] men health
care product thing that came to our
office it is just gone yeah so someone's
got our shampoo and [ __ ]
yeah somebody got shampoo at a camera
you know it's crazy so you know how like
this thing was going on right and
everyone's like be careful for your
packages so it's an extra paranoid
and I was expecting two shoes and it
never [ __ ] came right so I went to
Amazon and I just said I got jacked and
what they did is they sent me another
pair for free I feel like Amazon does
that very well but not have four shoes
because the other one was just late I'm
pretty sure that Amazon looks at how
much money you've spent with them too I
buy everything from Amazon I don't leave
the [ __ ] house if I die you know so
like even though that the same thing I
had like this battery and I order from
my camera it came in late yeah or like
the an email tells you to just keep it
if you want right yeah yeah I said okay
that's fine so I got two batteries I
could send it back but it's not cuz I'm
greedy it's because I'm lazy yes I don't
want to go to the post office and I
can't do it
it's pretty nice but I got four shoes
now quick tip you guys buy a lot of [ __ ]
on Amazon and pretend that you lost some
[ __ ] no don't do that that's [ __ ] up
what would the excuse me for you guys
when you she's like what are you doing
here what would you say instead of I
thought it was my package I would just
beat that girl that what
how to stop me from burglary [ __ ] you
beat the [ __ ] out of her so bad I mean
if I was in that person's shoes that's
not with you there's two ways you can do
this one is octopus your way up what
does that look like [ __ ] or do
the kid thing is just [ __ ] drop just
drop it yeah just touch it but why was
she running like that though which
Bishop heels knows what she's just bags
wedding shoes yes it's not like the
babysitter was a faster if it looked
like the Vegas girl shuffle you know
that when they got the heels and [ __ ] so
I thought she was wearing heels I think
because she's going downhill
that's a driveway gorilla take that down
I'm just trying to see why she would run
like that talking about the babysitter
know the thief yeah the boat like she
said her she was wearing slippers and
you could see her slippers fall out well
she's awesome that's some serious [ __ ]
you said miss fly off that's a dedicated
babysitter though for sure like if I was
a babysitter and I watch that she'll be
like oh hey you got your packages stolen
I'm not gonna chase after them like that
at my house the only thing I saw was the
USPS guy that we used to work there this
fool wouldn't even try to deliver our
packages like a I happen to just come
down at the same time and just for just
walked up I saw him park he gets out
writes a slip that nobody's there they
just put it right here you're not gonna
come up he goes oh I just uh
you know sometimes like I'm like nope so
I called you know and they you got I
think I fired because he got like deep
[ __ ] yeah he did it like two or three
times because I kept I stopped getting
my [ __ ] and you could just walk up to my
complex but he just walks in wrote his
[ __ ] put it he just tried to leave yeah
since my mom didn't teach me how to deal
with confrontations like that I'd
probably just look at the thief and be
like why do you talk so tough and [ __ ]
[ __ ]
this right here all the time
look at you okay okay okay yeah this is
my [ __ ] UFC robe when I come out of
shoes that would be very good I still
feel like you would make a great UFC
fighter
what does I think you would fight just
if it's a good look good branding I
would love to pay this is gonna kick
your ass what do you think you like cut
just you I just imagine you running
around the ring screaming is just so
much good entertainer I tell you this
though I'll be like John Jones though I
just go straight for I books all the
time do you get this qualified but
there's a that works job does it well he
also runs over pregnant women that's
cocaine so but there's this guy who was
my favorite fighter Fedor Emelianenko of
course the same body shape best
heavyweight of all time and he has a
little like just so cute and he looked
like a little baby but he does not look
he looks menacing he's awesome he looks
like a Russian [ __ ] assassin ever now
I've never seen fade or smile ever
well he's Russian he has a constant
smiles like this you seen that video of
him that when his brothers fighting yeah
they should be translate what he was
saying behind the screen he just like
sitting there mumbling like but what he
translated was like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
bucket hit and you [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm
all really like god this brother in
backstage she's watching him fight and
that's what he's mumbling under his
breath it's like oh my god dude
what a good brother story here so you
guys remember mine right yes yeah
that's a member by the Azzurri that [ __ ]
so long ago yes though one of the
cofounders his name is Don Hoffman
tweeted this so dumb oh I knew it
I think it's too late yeah so we don't
know well everyone's on Instagram now
yeah the public make it longer to throw
six seconds over like what there
some [ __ ] yeah so this is all like
speculation that they might come out
with a vine to kind of ask no one bought
vine
no no one so they thought is worthless
apparently maybe the I mean the platform
is kind of interesting because this is a
six second video platform how do you run
ads on a six seconds by this did you
guys try it did you guys ever use it see
if you can monetize it fit in no I never
try we we did it in the beginning yeah
we actually created a little bit of
content because you know the popular
guys on vine they were or France or they
are friends but then they left mine and
they're doing YouTube and all that stuff
the issue is even for a lot of top
Viners is they couldn't monetize off the
platforms so they all got together they
asked you know vine headquarters is like
hey how can we we want to do this for a
living so like how can we take it to the
next level and they never figured it out
mmm so that's the biggest issue is like
people stick with things like YouTube
maybe maybe Instagram because they can
figure out a way to monetize it I think
for vine specifically they're gonna
that's going to be their biggest issue
to attract creators that are like
longtime like solid liners I just don't
want another platform we already have so
much Instagram Facebook now it's MySpace
dylath-leen
no what about xanga omegle was the [ __ ]
though you got a bigger page it's gone
out they don't even have the really yeah
oh those a point where Zenga pointed out
that if you wanted to like download your
[ __ ] that you wrote you can't because
you're just getting rid of it
you guys remember Asian a pan-asian
Avenue early 2000s like a blog you don't
know I thought you wouldn't know Asian
Avenue the hell that the Asian [ __ ] I
mean but not like pretend like I'm Asian
yeah but you go hunting on there right
are you an Asian by you know what does
that mean yes so big yellow fever yellow
fever basically or you're very like like
our producer George he doesn't want to
admit it but is for sure in Asia fine
well he looks like he jacks off the
blurred porno though
yeah he likes they say he sees a real
butthole is it uh see you've learned a
lot like I feel like anything he sees
pixelate he's like oh [ __ ] it triggers
him a little bit
no mi mi you guys like Asian food how
many Asian guys
well we can't really say that cuz
haven't had that many boyfriends and so
out of the four boyfriends that I've had
they're either more Asian will bring an
environment where they're a lot a lot
yeah yeah so I grew up with a lot of
Asian heard the circumstantial so
circumstantially like George is
different like he didn't grow up around
any Asian people but he'd massive that's
true cause she grew up works mainly
Latino and Asian yeah people Japanese on
to you that like taught me at like I
knew how to use chopsticks at a really
young age and I knew a lot of Japanese
[ __ ] mmm got it yeah George is different
he's you know he didn't grow up around
any so like the first chance he got he
went to Asia
oh what a weirdo
[Music]
this Sonny goes like George's George to
me it's like the textbook if you look
the white person like George's picture
pops up dude picture of him like right
here so he was wearing a [ __ ] Ascot
yeah yeah we need to have a picture of
George so people know what we're back
that is a plantation scar editor's put a
picture of George right here so everyone
knows put a couple just put [ __ ] love
George but you know when he gets angry
his curse words are [ __ ] fruity as
hell yeah williger's come on George get
the [ __ ] out of here I love you dude
[Music]